RICHARD HYNDMAN: Oh, this
is definitely on.
Hi there.
And welcome to this talk on
Bluetooth best practices.
My name is Richard Hyndman.
I'm on the Android team.
And I head up Android Developer
Relations for Europe.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: I'm
Scout Sinclair Brody.
I'm a product manager on
the Android platform.
MATTHEW XIE: Hi.
My name is Matthew Xie.
I'm the Android tech
lead for Bluetooth.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK, let's get
this show on the road.
So thank you all for
coming today.
I'm pretty sure that some of
you out there must have
suffered at the hands of
this technology before.
Yeah, right.
We all have.
So thank you very much for
coming along, being
open-minded, and listening to
what we have to say about
Android on Bluetooth today.
So, picture the scene.
The year is--
who can get the year?
First person?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD HYNDMAN: No.
1994.
It's quite a tricky one.
It's a bad year for
Roman numerals.
But the people over at Ericsson
were sick and tired
of having to reach around to the
back of their computers to
plug-in their serial cables.
They tried turning their
computers around.
But then the power buttons
were on the wrong side.
So like any good '90s innovative
company, they
decided to reinvent
the whole system.
And they came up with Bluetooth,
as we know, for
wirelessly connecting devices,
peer-to-peer over short ranges.
Bluetooth's named after Harold
Blatand Gormsson, Blatand
being "blue tooth" in English.
He was a Danish King that united
tribes together without
the use of serial cables.
So that was kind of handy.
It's a good name for
the technology.
So you get the H from Harold--
it's a rune--, and the rune
for B. Put them together, and
you get this bindrune that's
the Bluetooth logo.
We've had Bluetooth
on Android--
there he is--
since version 1.0.
That's my favorite animation
all deck.
And we had Bluetooth 2.0
with the EDR stack--
headset profile, handset
profile, but no real APIs.
So you can use Classic Bluetooth
to connect music to
music players, mice to
laptops, or mice with
headphones to anything
you want.
But the point is, these things
need to be able to talk to
each other.
The need to be able to
discover each other.
They need to be able
to connect.
And they need to be able to
talk a common language.
And for that, they're going
to need a Bluetooth stack.
So what's a Bluetooth stack?
A Bluetooth stack is an
implementation of the
Bluetooth Core Specification.
On the bottom of it, you've got
the RF Transceiver doing
the actual wireless
communications.
Above that, you've got the
Baseband controlling the
Transceiver.
Above that, you've got
the Protocol Stack.
Lots and lots of protocols
all going into
there, so you can talk.
Lots of different types of
communication between any two
Bluetooth devices.
So this is a Bluetooth stack.
And then on top of that, you
have your Bluetooth Profiles.
Bluetooth Profiles are
definitions of--
[MICROPHONE FEEDBACK]
Bluetooth Profiles are
definitions of which parts of
the Bluetooth stack are required
for doing each type
of communication.
Bluetooth Profiles generally
aren't tied in to any specific
version of the stack.
They're just definitions--
which codex you need,
which parts of the
stack do you need.
So when you see versions of
Bluetooth, you're looking at
versions of the core
specification.
Version 1, version 1.1, which
was 802.15, the Bluetooth spec
was running about a
megabit a second.
Version 2 went up to about
three mega second.
The little + EDR means
in Enhanced
Data Rate is optional.
Version 3, they claim, was
around 24 megabits a second.
Not sure I ever got
that out of it.
With the + HS for plus High
Speed is an 802.11 Wi-Fi link.
Which brings us up
to version 4.
Let's just say there have been
many, many different Bluetooth
stack implementations.
In Android, we've had the BlueZ
stack, powering AOSP
devices, Samsung and HTC
devices, Sony Xperias.
We've also had the Older
Broadcom Stack.
Some of the HTC before Ice
Cream Sandwich devices.
We've got a Motorola Bluetooth
Stack for all
host Motorola devices.
And then some others as well.
And of course, these
are all compatible.
But software has bugs in it.
We know that software
has bugs in it.
So potentially, you have to work
around different issues,
just little things here
and there with all
the different stacks.
And whilst we've had all these
different stacks, the Android
APIs that have been available to
developers and the Android
Bluetooth functionality
available to consumers has
also been changing throughout
the history of Bluetooth.
Matt's just going to run through
quickly the different
APIs we've had on Bluetooth
through the years.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah, hi.
I'm going to just go over
Android Bluetooth versions
features APIs a little
quickly.
So as you know, Android
loves desserts.
So you could say we have
a real sweet Bluetooth.
Starting at the beginning,
we included Bluetooth.
So Android 1.0, we have
Bluetooth 2.0 with a headset
and hands-free profile.
So you can make a phone call
using your Bluetooth headset
[INAUDIBLE].
Now, Cupcake, we have a A2DP.
You can stream music
over Bluetooth.
Next is Eclair.
We have Bluetooth 2.1
with RFCOMM APIs.
And we also added object push
and the phonebook profiles.
Then with Froyo, voice dialing
over Bluetooth.
Honeycomb, we added APIs for
profiles, like A2DP and
hands-free.
Honeycomb also added
[INAUDIBLE]
PAN tethering, which is you
can connect your Bluetooth
keyboard, mouse, game pad, and
typing instead of doing that
on your phone.
And PAN is data tethering so
you can share your internet
using Bluetooth.
And ICS added a Health Device
Profile so you can stream your
medical data real-time
over Bluetooth.
And then now, it's Jelly Bean.
Over to Scout.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
So as you may know--
whoops, went back
for a second.
Try it again.
Whoop, too far.
There we go.
OK, so as you may
know, in 4.2, we
introduced a new stack.
We moved away from BlueZ
to BlueDroid.
This was a change that was made
possible by a significant
contribution to AOSP
by Broadcom.
There were, of course, some
bumps in the road with this
transition, for which we
certainly apologize.
But we felt that it
was an important
move on several levels.
First, we wanted a stack
that was optimized
for embedded systems.
Second, because of conflicting
licensing models, we actually
had to run BlueZ in its own
process, which certainly had
performance implications.
And finally, we really felt that
having stack development
happen in AOSP would allow
greater overall velocity, in
terms of adding features and
adding stability and
performance enhancements
over time.
So that brings us to a topic
that many folks are interested
in, which is Bluetooth
Low Energy.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Clearly,
there's a lot of excitement
about this technology.
And I'm not sure that all of
you are familiar with it.
So I want to tell you a little
bit about what it
is and why it exists.
Bluetooth, as it was originally
conceived, was
designed to interact, allow
devices with relatively large
batteries that charge frequently
to interact with
one another.
And as Rich mentioned, use cases
for Bluetooth Classic
typically involved streaming
audio or other high bandwidth
applications.
However, the original
specification was a little bit
heavy for devices that have very
small batteries or that
you don't want to charge
every day.
So Bluetooth Low Energy was
designed to work with devices
in exactly this category.
Such as proximity tags that you
can attach to your keys to
help you find them, or
pedometers or fitness or
medical sensors, or
watches, or game
controllers, remote controls.
There are a whole host of
possibilities with this
technology.
The goal is to let devices that
run on small batteries
like these to go for
years at a time
without being recharged.
The technology that we
colloquially refer to as
Bluetooth Low Energy
is actually--
the official brand name of it,
as propagated by the Bluetooth
SIG, is Bluetooth SMART for
devices that support just BLE,
and Bluetooth SMART READY for
devices that support both BLE
and Bluetooth Classic.
So you might be wondering why
I'm showing a Nexus 4 here.
Because, up until this point,
of course, we have not had
support for Bluetooth
Low Energy
in the Android platform.
But today, we are excited to
announce that when Android API
version 18 is released in a
couple of short months, the
Nexus 4 and all future Nexus
devices will support Bluetooth
Low Energy with developer-facing
APIs.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: So this
means that your apps and your
peripheral devices can take
full advantage of this
exciting technology.
So in a couple of minutes, we're
going to go through a
couple of code examples, and
you'll get a preview of the
APIs for Bluetooth Low Energy.
But I want to give you a bit of
terminology first that will
help you in understanding
when we walk
through those examples.
First off, you should know
that BLE is based on the
specification called GATT, which
is what your apps will
actually interface with.
GATT communicates using the
attribute protocol, which,
true to its name, transfers data
in the form of attributes
and operations on those
attributes.
The most basic type of
attributes are descriptors and
characteristics.
A descriptor, also true to its
name, is just a descriptive
tag for another piece of data.
A characteristic consists of
a value and a zero or more
descriptors associated
with it.
The Bluetooth SIG has adopted
a number of standard
characteristics for expressing
such diverse information as
the day of the week or a blood
glucose value or a sensor's
location on a bicycle.
I mean, there are all sorts
of crazy things in there.
Characteristics can then be
grouped together to form a
service, which a BLE
device can then
advertise to other devices.
A service spec states not only
the characteristics that a
GATT service makes available,
but also which characteristics
the GATT clients can read,
write, or receive
notifications about.
Note that when two BLE-enabled
devices are communicating,
either one can act as the
client or the server.
They can even switch off.
It all depends on which
one is actually making
characteristics available
to the other one.
Moving up in the specification,
the next bit here--
sorry, there's the client
and server.
The next bit here is GATT
profiles, which define how
data provided by a service is
to be exchanged between the
GATT server and its clients.
Profiles are defined with
specific use cases in mind,
but are generally designed
to be flexible enough to
accommodate multiple scenarios
within a particular domain.
As of right now, there are about
20 different ones for a
bunch of different use cases.
And as of Android API version
18, you will be able to
implement these profiles in your
apps, or future profiles
that are released, or custom
profiles that you want to
define for your application.
Back to Rich.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Thank
you very much.
OK, so we had a quick
look at the
Bluetooth stack for Classic.
Next, we've got the Bluetooth
stack for Low Energy as well.
The point being, here, that at
the bottom you've got a low
energy RF now.
This is optimized.
Instead of streaming data like
the Classic stack, just for
bursting out these small
attributes of data and then
powering back down again, this
is how Bluetooth Low Energy
stays so low energy.
And the protocol stack, instead
of being this enormous
array of protocols, is
really focused on the
one attribute profile.
And on the profiles at the
top, instead of all the
different profiles, we've
just got this GATT
profile on the top.
So the Bluetooth LE stack is a
fraction of the size of the
Bluetooth Classic stack.
And because of the low energy
RF, it needs a fraction of the
size battery.
And you get these devices, of
course, that are a fraction of
the cost and run for
a lot longer.
So as this talk's called
Bluetooth Best Practices, we
should have a look at some of
Bluetooth's best practices.
To demo this, we're going to
run through an example of
connecting a Bluetooth heart
rate monitor to a Nexus 4.
This is going to be, right now,
the only place where you
can see the Bluetooth LE APIs
that we've created.
So here we go.
Although, to start with, you
always need to check if the
device has Bluetooth.
When I was writing this slide,
I was thinking, what devices
don't have Bluetooth?
I almost took the slide
back out again.
And then I thought, only the
devices inside our ecosystem
are CTS-tested.
And they're the only ones that
we can guarantee that have
Bluetooth on.
So maybe there are non-Bluetooth
devices.
And then there's going to be
things like Google TVs that
also may not be Bluetooth
devices.
So it avoids horrific crashes.
It's always worth checking
if you have
Bluetooth on the device.
Matt's just going to run you
through the code quickly.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah so let's talk
a little about the code.
To check whether there's
Bluetooth on your device or
not, you check Bluetooth
Adapter.
This is existing API.
But the only way you'll get it
is you're seeing static method
with a Bluetooth Adapter,
Get Default Adapter.
If you look at this code,
we are changing that.
We're obsoleting that.
Now we are doing this with
our Bluetooth Manager.
So you see context, Get
System Service,
with Bluetooth Service.
And then, from the Manager, you
get the Bluetooth Adapter.
And now you check, if that's
null, then you don't have
Bluetooth support in
your platform.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK, so we've
got a device with Bluetooth.
Of course, you're next going
to need to check whether
Bluetooth's turned on
or off to avoid the
next horrific crash.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah, you do
this by we provide API.
You do this by check
from the Adapter.
You check whether it's
enabled or not.
If it's not enabled, you can
send an Intent to the
[INAUDIBLE] app to enable it.
We don't have an API to enable
it directly, because we want
full user awareness.
So you cannot sneak
Bluetooth on
without the user's knowledge.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, so you
fire off the intent to get the
Bluetooth setting screens up.
Right, so now we're ready to
connect the Bluetooth LE
device to the phone.
So we have a new flow for
Bluetooth Low Energy.
We start with a low
energy scan.
And that's going to put the
device in scanning mode and
look for any devices--
any low-energy devices--
that are currently advertising
their presence and available
for connections.
You find the one that you want,
you stop the scanning,
and you connect to the device.
Once you're connected,
you discover the
services of the device.
In the case of a heart rate
monitor, it's going to have
the heart rate service.
Then you can find the
characteristics of the service.
This is all about how the
GATT profile works.
Characteristics of a heart rate
service, one's definitely
going to be the heart
rate, the pulse.
Another one could be the
location of the pulse that
it's checking on the body.
Maybe you've got it around your
wrist, or around your
chest or something.
So you can then find the heart
rate and then read it.
You can either just read the
attributes for the heart rate
or register to get notifications
about them.
And here's the code for that.
MATTHEW XIE: First, you want
to discover the BLE device.
We provided a new API to do that
in the Bluetooth Adapter.
This is just for LE device.
You do Start LE Scan.
We have two APIs.
One is just API with
a callback.
The other, you can pass in UUID
filters to filter out
only the device you're
interested in.
And this API is callback
based.
We send out results through
callback, so you have to
implement the LE Scan Callback
API with an LE scan.
And there are three parameters
we're going to call you.
One is a device.
That's the one you
want to find out.
And RSSI, which Receive
the Signal Strength.
And the Scans Record is the
advertisement data in a byte
rate format.
OK, now if all you're interested
in is just the
advertisement data,
then you're done.
But if you want to use the
service hosted by the remote
BLE device, you need
to connect to it.
You do this by Bluetooth
Device Connect GATT.
With this, you connect
to the remote device.
This is also on callback
based.
If you look there, there's
a few callback functions,
because the Connect call or
Discovery call or Character
Read or Write call
are asynchronous.
So you'll implement the
callback function.
And when there's results coming
back, we will call the
callback functions.
Take the example, like say, when
you see like Discover a
Service, we'll call back with
onServiceDiscovered with a
write status.
And then you can say Get
Services to catch the service.
So with a service is a list
of Bluetooth GATT service.
So you traverse the services.
For each service, you can
just go to look for
characteristics, or you can
use UUID to find out the
service you are interested.
And then, the same way, you go
into each service and Get
Characteristics, which is
a list of Bluetooth GATT
characteristic.
With that you can check UUIDs
and look for the UUID your
user is interested.
Like in this example, trying to
match the heart rate UUID
and get that.
And then, you can also
set notification.
And so we'll notify you if the
characteristic changes.
Now back to Scout.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: OK.
So there's your sneak peek at
the BLE APIs for Android.
This is an exciting
technology.
And we know that you're
looking forward to
working with it.
There are a few other things
that we think you should bear
in mind, though, as you're
preparing to do so.
First off, since BLE will be
introduced in Android API
version 18, you'll need a
device running the next
version of Android before
you can take
advantage of these APIs.
However, once they are released,
they will be covered
by the compatibility program in
the same way that Bluetooth
Classic APIs are, which means
you can count on them being
present in new and
updated devices
throughout the ecosystem.
Next, we want you to know that
the first version of these
APIs have support for the BLE
central role but not the
peripheral role.
This means that you won't be
able to have two Android
devices talking to each other
across the BLE, at least not
to begin with.
Next, and speaking to the
nature of the technology
itself, please remember that
Bluetooth is not a type of
magic fairy dust that you can
sprinkle on your existing apps
and have them become suddenly
more battery efficient.
It is a different technology
with very distinctly
different use cases.
And this is a common
thing that I'll see
in talking to people.
They'll say, oh, and
now we've got BLE!
Everything's going to be much
more battery efficient.
I'm going to have much
better battery life.
Well, it doesn't exactly
work that way.
The data model for Bluetooth
Low Energy is optimized for
small incremental updates.
With a max theoretical
throughput of 200 kilobits per
second, streaming audio or video
is really not possible.
However, if you're looking to
send data over from a sensor
of some sort or if you're super
forgetful and want to
have BLE proximity tags attached
to everything you
own, Bluetooth Low Energy is
going to be a fantastic option
and definitely a more
power-efficient way to go than
Classic Bluetooth.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Right,
of course.
Whenever you're on a mobile OS,
battery is always a concern.
When you're running wireless
communications on a mobile OS,
it's even more of a concern.
So just a couple of little
battery tips
for Classic and LE.
When you're scanning for
devices, once you've found the
device you're looking for, of
course, tell the system that
you've found it and turn
off the scanning.
This also serves another
purpose, because there's
definitely, with some of the
stacks, some conflict when
you're trying to make an RFCOMM
connection with the
device you've just found--
and some people are nodding
quite a lot--
and if you're still
discovering.
So don't have Discovery on while
you try and make the
connection, and you'll also
save a bit of battery.
Also, never loop on
any RF functions.
There are wireless devices.
One might go out of range.
It might lose its battery
or something.
So if you're trying to connect
to a device and you fail, then
just ask the user or do some
intelligent logic about
whether they want to
reconnect again.
Don't just sit there looping
on the radio.
We've see it one or two times,
and then, of course, it just
depletes the battery, especially
if you're in a
background service and the user
doesn't know what's going
on, trying to reconnect to
something that existed before.
Also, don't reinvent
the wheel.
Android Beam is pretty
established now.
If you want to do a Bluetooth
file transfer, for example,
NFC is a great way for doing the
Bluetooth handshake at the
start, for getting the details
of the two devices.
And with Android Beam, you
just have to set the
BeamPushUris or the
CreateBeamUrisCallback.
And you can make it so when the
two devices touch, a large
file is sent between
the two of them.
Android Beam will do the
negotiation and send the file
over Bluetooth for you.
There's something to
do with the RFCOMM
APIs again, as well.
Initial APIs listen using
RFCOMM and create RFCOMM
sockets secure APIs.
And that means that they need
both devices to have a screen
and I/O to be able to make the
secure connection, because you
need to do all the
pin entry stuff.
So if you try and make a secure
connection, or if you
just try and use these APIs
and it fails, one of the
reasons may be that the target
device can't display a pin.
If that's the case, go back
to be insecure APIs at the
bottom, create Insecure and
Listen Insecure, and it'll
create the connection
much more simply.
To be honest, most the time,
you don't need to use the
secure APIs.
If you've got both devices in
your hand, the chance of a man
in the middle attack
is pretty slim.
So you're going to save yourself
a lot of bother
inside your application if you
just go with the insecure
ones, because there's
a lot less reasons
why they would fail.
One last thing.
What would any good Bluetooth
talk be without a
final little teaser?
A think it's a good point.
We've got this whole
new stack in there.
We're announcing a
few other things.
So I'm very happy to say that
also within API 18, in a few
short months, we will be adding
support for AVRCP 1.3.
And to the people in the
audience that that means
something to, they'll be
quite happy about that.
[INAUDIBLE] will be very happy
about that, because he pings
me about it every day.
AVRCP 1.0 was in an earlier
version of Android, and it
meant you could connect your
phone to your car stereo and
do the remote control.
With 1.3, we also add all
the meta data as well.
So you'll see your album art.
You'll see your track numbers,
track listing, album and
titles, that kind of
thing, as well.
So of course, there has to be
an API for that as well.
And it's using an existing
API-- the Remote Control
Client API.
So anything that's already using
Remote Control Client--
and Google Music certainly does,
and a lot of apps have
Remote Control Clients
already--
will automatically
work for you.
And your car stereo will get all
the awesome information.
If you want to have a look
inside the API, have a look
inside the Media Metadata
Retriever, and there's a whole
load of different tags
inside there that you
can set on the API.
Things like the album art,
things like that.
And one final thing, make sure
you always call clear on the
metadata [INAUDIBLE]
first, or you're going to mix
your metadata up with whatever
metadata was in there first.
And it gets all a bit crazy.
OK.
Back to Scout to wrap it up.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
All right.
So we've had a couple of
exciting announcements,
including the inclusion of
Bluetooth Low Energy APIs in
API version 18, along
with AVRCP 1.3.
We have Office Hours immediately
following the
session, over in the Android
Sandbox that
you're welcome to join.
I think we seem to have gone
relatively quickly, so we've
got some time for questions
now as well.
But of course, if you want to
find out more about the
Bluetooth APIs and anything
relating to Android, as
always, you should definitely
check out
the developer website.
And there's a specific link
right there to the Bluetooth
information.
And let's have you step
up to the mics if
you have any questions.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Thank
you very much.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
All right.
So it's hard to tell.
I think we've got at
least one question.
So why don't you go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Jimmy [? Bocham ?]
from [? Stickerpoint. ?]
I have a question about
the new API for
Bluetooth Low Energy.
The first question is, will it
support multiple devices
connected at the same time?
And the second question, will
it support devices calling
specific apps?
So if the app is not running
in the background, will you
support this?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: OK.
So let's take them
one at a time.
First was--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Will
it be able to
connect to multiple devices.
AUDIENCE: Multiple connections
at the same time.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah.
Yeah, that's a central.
Yeah, we can connect to
multiple peripherals.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: OK, so if
you're running in central
mode, such as you're
on the phone--
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah, we
are able to do that.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: --it
can connect to multiple
peripherals.
And then the second?
AUDIENCE: The second question
was regarding if an LE device
can call a specific app
that is not running.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah, so with
these callback functions.
Even if it's switched in
the background, we will
still call you back.
AUDIENCE: So if the app is not
running, and the LE device--
or the phone is on background.
It could be on standby or
its on the background.
And a specific device that
you've connected before that
hasn't appeared before comes
into range, will you allow to
call a specific app?
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah.
I think your app, you have
to implement our service.
So that, if its activity,
if you are tending the
background, it's stopped.
But if you have a service,
then we will call that.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, the
scanning on the device isn't
going to be scanning for new
advertising devices that are
coming past the whole time.
The radio is not on scanning
the whole time.
So it won't know that a random
device has just come into
range, I believe.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So you'd have
to have a service that scans
to try to find devices
that are--
AUDIENCE: So you need to have
it in the background.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah, you would
still need to have a
service in the background.
And that would not be great
for the battery, maybe.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: OK,
so let's alternate.
So let's go on this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
I have a question.
I noticed you didn't mention
any sort of backwards
compatibility.
Is there any hope of that?
And do you think there's any
prospects on backporting it?
Is that even possible?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: So what we're
saying is that it's going to
be API level 18 and above and
not be in the compatibility
test suite.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: And
this is very common.
When a new API is introduced,
it's for that API version.
It doesn't necessarily
go backwards in time.
AUDIENCE: So I've already
started using the Motorola,
the HTC, and the Samsung
BLE library SDKs.
Is it going to be--
RICHARD HYNDMAN: That's
definitely an option.
Going forward though, of course,
all those devices will
also, when they get to API 18,
have to support the official
framework instead of BLE APIs
So if you do want to support
those current SDKs that
are out there,
that's absolutely fine.
As always, with Android,
it's open.
But going forward, yeah, you
just have to support this one
set of APIs, and it'll make
your life a lot easier.
AUDIENCE: To support multiple
devices connected at the same
time, when the app is
in the background,
how do I know which--
like, in a proximity
case, there are
multiple Bluetooth tags.
And how can I distinguish
whether a particular--
few tags are of interest
to me, that are mine.
There could be other tags
which are not mine.
So how do I take care of such
a kind of situation.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Under
the assumption that you've
been encountered these
tags before?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is there an association
in Bluetooth LE?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Well you can
associate inside your
application with the
ID from the tag.
So the first time you
get the tag, you can
say, this is my keys.
Inside your app, it says
it's found the tag.
And you could give
it a name inside
your app, if you wanted.
But each BLE device is a unique
ID that you'll be able
to reference again
when you see it.
AUDIENCE: So it's completely
application-based?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it's not anything
to do with the stack itself?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: No.
AUDIENCE: Or the OS?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Entirely
up to the application.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Albert.
What LE profiles will
be supported when
API 18 comes out?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: So
right now we support--
there's GATT.
There's support for GATT.
And you can implement support
for GATT profiles in your
application.
AUDIENCE: So you're expecting
LE profiles like heart rate
monitors and [INAUDIBLE]
GATT to be distributed over
the Google Play Store?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: They
all run over GATT.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Yes,
they all run over GATT in
Bluetooth Low Energy.
AUDIENCE: And they can be
distributed over the Google
Play Store?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Yeah,
it's part of your app.
AUDIENCE: Is GATT server
will be supported?
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah.
We support.
We also open up API to
support GATT server.
AUDIENCE: GATT server.
How about GATT over basic
rate over EDR?
MATTHEW XIE: Say it again?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: GATT
on Bluetooth--
AUDIENCE: GATT over basic
rate over EDR.
So in the Bluetooth
specification, GATT could run
over Low Energy protocol,
and also could run
over basic rate EDR?
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah, we also
support that, yes.
So if it's on the basic rate,
the API will still work.
Yes.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Can you
turn the mic back on?
Go ahead.
No, you should be fine.
I was asking the tech
folks to turn--
AUDIENCE: Oh, hello?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
You're good.
AUDIENCE: I didn't
get the answer.
I'm sorry.
MATTHEW XIE: The answer is,
the same API will work
in that case, too.
Like, GATT over basic rate.
AUDIENCE: And you mentioned
earlier that the peripheral
role is not supported.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: The
peripheral role is not
implemented for API version
18 at this point, no.
AUDIENCE: How about the
observer role and the
advertiser role?
So in the GATT specification,
there's four roles-- the
central, peripheral, observer,
and the advertiser.
Will the other two roles
be supported, as well?
MATTHEW XIE: You're talking
about the broadcaster?
AUDIENCE: The broadcaster.
Observer.
MATTHEW XIE: No broadcaster.
Observer, yes.
AUDIENCE: No broadcaster.
MATTHEW XIE: At this point.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: We're still
making these APIs.
MATTHEW XIE: API 18, no.
We don't do advertisement.
We do scanning for the
advertisements.
So we are in the central
role, basically.
So one, the broadcaster role
or the observer role that
you're talking about, that
doesn't really apply to us,
because we have TX and RX.
We have both TX RX.
Does that answer
your question?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Maybe this
is something that we can
continue during Office
Hours, if that's OK.
Can you make it to
Office Hours?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MATTHEW XIE: So in short, we
do central, and that's it.
With central, we can scan
advertisements.
So you have observer there,
supporting it in default, too.
No broadcaster or peripheral
at this point for API 18.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: Thanks.
Let's move over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Diego.
I work for a company that does
multiple mobile platforms.
Is this going to
be available--
is this going to work also with
other platforms like iOS
or Windows phones that already
support Bluetooth 4.0?
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
Well, so it depends.
I'm actually not familiar
whether or not those devices
support the peripheral role.
Because in Android API version
18, we only support the
central role.
So if they can do peripheral,
then we can talk to them.
But if they only do central as
well, then as of API 18, no,
you won't be able to talk over
BLE with the devices.
Basically, you need something
that can be
in peripheral mode.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was curious about APTX or "apt
x", higher dynamic range
Bluetooth streaming audio.
Is that going to be
supported in AOSP?
Or is that just relegated to
Samsung, HTC, and others that
pay a license fee?
I'm just curious.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY: So as
far as I know, that's not
something that we have working
for this next version.
And in general, we don't comment
on things that are
happening after that.
So definitely stop by Office
Hours to talk about it and
make sure that we understand
your use cases and what you
envision this being
useful for.
Because it can be useful for
us in sort of prioritizing
what features and what aspects
of the spec we go for next.
But at this point, we won't
comment on things like that.
Sorry.
All right.
I guess one more over
here, and then we
head to Office Hours.
AUDIENCE: This is just
a curiosity.
The iOS Bluetooth stack
rotates MAC
addresses every 15 minutes.
Does the Android stack do
anything like that?
It's a privacy feature,
currently.
MATTHEW XIE: I think we do.
We do that, yes.
AUDIENCE: And, just curious.
What type of range have you
guys seen on Android's
peripheral?
Like, how many feet?
RICHARD HYNDMAN: Have
we tried that?
Mine works from here
to here quite well.
AUDIENCE: Six inches?
Twelve inches?
MATTHEW XIE: More than that.
I think it's--
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
Obviously it
depends on the device.
MATTHEW XIE: Yeah, it depends
on the device.
About ten meters, I would say.
AUDIENCE: So one
last question.
The RSSI, is that going to be
normalized across devices?
So if I have two devices, like a
Samsung and an HTC, and they
both report, say, at an RSSI of
85, would they be about the
same distance?
Or is it calibrated per device
or per radio [INAUDIBLE]
or something?
MATTHEW XIE: That's
a good question.
I think it's calibrated.
AUDIENCE: That would be great
for the CTS or whatever, to
make sure that those are
consistent, because otherwise
we'd have to check
it manually.
Thank you.
SCOUT SINCLAIR BRODY:
Makes sense.
All right, on to Office Hours.
Thank you all for your time.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: The Office
Hours is on the third floor,
at the back of the
Android area.
Thanks very much.
MATTHEW XIE: Thank you.